alright ladies and gentlemen welcome to
our webinar today on the bulk conversion
of GI numbers to exact version
identifiers I'm Eric sayers and i'll be
speaking you to you for a few minutes
today about this topic if there are
questions that we don't get to today we
will be posting answers to those
questions with the other webinar
materials and you can find that at the
webinars page that we have listed there
also and there's also a go USA gov URL
to the materials and those will be up
later today so let's go ahead and get
started what we're going to talk about
today this is essentially the third
webinar in a series of webinars about
changes to sequence identifiers at NCBI
and I'm just going to a little bit of
holiday festivities here just switch for
a moment to a command line and I'm going
to tell you what I'm doing in a moment
but I'm going to start a little process
here that I will explain a little bit
later so off it runs and I'm going to do
a couple other things with that and
we'll come back to that in a moment so
what I'd like to do is talk to you today
about a couple of different things that
we've been attempting to do with GI
numbers and accessions so one of the
things that we've talked about the last
couple of webinars one on July twentieth
and sep tember seventh is the fact that
we've been changing some of the ways
that we are dealing with sequins
identifiers the main thing that is
happening is that sequences that have gi
numbers will continue to have gi numbers
going forward but new sequences more and
more new sequences will not be assigned
GI numbers so we are going to be
switching to accessioned version as the
primary identifier for sequence records
and that's something that everyone needs
to become more aware of and again you
can go back and look at those two ebon
ours that we've had before to understand
more about that I want to talk a little
bit as introduction to this webinar
about something we talked about on
September seventh which is how you can
use a fetch to handle a certain number
of GI numbers and convert them to
accession duck version because one of
the things that we understand is as this
process unfolds you may need to convert
GI numbers
gene systems to accession versions but
the real motivation behind what we're
doing today is that you can do many more
of these if you would like so again to
summarize the things that are changing
we're phasing out the usage of the
sequence identifiers called GI numbers
existing GI numbers will remain
indefinitely all right so if a sequence
has a GI number now it will continue to
have a GI number and you can continue to
use that for retrieval the real issue
our sequences that will not have gi
numbers assigned to them those sequences
in particular are things like w GS and
TS a transcript shotgun assembly
sequences which many of which do not
have gi numbers now in any case and more
and more of those will not to have gi
numbers so those sequences are a problem
in terms of trying to get GI numbers
currently that will that problem if you
will will continue to grow as we are
unable to sign GI numbers to more and
more of those sequences currently blast
fast a databases for example do not
contain GIS in definition lines anymore
and you also won't see GI numbers on the
default web displays of sequence records
so for example the flat file records and
fast day formats no longer have gi
numbers in them by default I mean I
should emphasize that the GI numbers are
still present in records that have them
they're just not displayed on those
default web displays and on things like
the blast definition lines but after
March fifteenth of next year none of the
formats flat file fast state record
formats across in CBI will contain GI
numbers including the GenBank and refseq
releases on the ftp side so we realize
that if you already have a system that
has GI numbers in it you will need to
convert them to accession version in
September and the last webinar we talked
about a way in which you can use the e
fetch a utility to do this for a smaller
number of GIS so if you have on the
order of several hundred or maybe a
small number of thousands you can do
this and I won't talk about this in the
detail you can go back to that webinar
but the basic idea is you can use an API
call such as
here to get back a list of Accession dot
versions that conform to or correspond
to your input set of GI numbers I'm
including bad GI numbers so if you 100
for example is no longer a valid GI
number that record was removed so if you
do that you would get a blank in your
output so that all works fine if you
have a small number but the real
question that we first had to address is
what if you had a really large number
you know you can do about maybe 250 or
so GIS per URL if you're using HTTP post
URL maybe around several thousand you
can do it once but because of our our
policies of use of AP is which no more
than about three calls per second if you
have hundreds of thousands or perhaps
millions of GIS that you need to convert
this is not the most practical way of
doing it and so what other things could
we offer to allow bulk conversion of GIS
so enter this new resource that we've
now released on our ftp site so the
resource is actually two things it is a
python script called GI to accession and
it is an accompanying database alright
that contains all of the information so
the database is actually in binary so
you're not going to be able to look at
it directly you need the Python script
to kind of decomp d convoluted and the
encrypt that database for you alright so
the script is designed to run locally so
the idea here is that you would download
all of this on to your own machine
that's great because then you don't
depend on a network connection or API
traffic or anything you just have to
depend on your own machines you need to
be aware that the database file is large
it'll be about 40 gigabytes when you
uncompress it so you need to have some
space on a disk to contain it but you
can get it and then use it locally the
database file contains all GI numbers
that exist including nucleotide and
protein genbank refseq you name it
they're all there including old GIS all
right so GI is from previous versions of
records so everything's there in one one
place we are updating this database
every day all right which is useful to
know the database changes every day so
if you get it on one particular day
you're going to get the snapshot of the
database at that time if you need to do
this conversion process again you very
well may want to come back and get the
most recent copy of the database just to
make sure you have full coverage now one
of the things that we anticipate about
this is that if probably for many folks
is a one-time operation in that you
already have a big database of GIS you
want their equivalent accession one time
you can do a conversion you can then map
the two and that's all you'll need to do
and then you can continue to update your
local databases and other services so
it's not something that we envision is
being an on-demand service to be used
frequently if that's not the case for
you please let us know but that's why
we've come a design this is one bolt
download that you can do once and then
kind of get it over with so how do you
get this well it lives on an FTP site
here GenBank live list then GI to act
underscore mapping so you go there
you'll find a number of different files
one of the files will be GI to accession
pie so that's of course the Python
script another file will be this GI to
act underscore LMD BG BG z so that is
the thing that you need to download and
that's about nine gigabytes compressed
you will also find in the ftp file an
umber of other files which are older
snapshots of that single database file
but you if you point to this particular
file name you will always get the most
recent version of the file so that's the
one to remember if you want to go back
and get an older one for whatever reason
you can do that also a useful thing to
know is that we have checked some files
for that database file also on the ftp
site md5 and sha-1 so you can use either
one of those to perform a checksum after
you've downloaded it it's probably a
useful thing to do just to make sure
that your download is complete what do
you do to install it so first obviously
unpack the
archive with gunzip or some tool like
that and again it's going to blow up
about four fold so about 40 gigs of
space that you'll need you need a python
environment of some kind we tend to use
virtual environments here there's a
variety of ways that you can do that but
you need a 2.7 or later Python
environment and you need the lmd be
packaged all right and we put a hero a
simple pip command that you can use to
install that package once you get that
package that's all you really need you
should be good to go so the script runs
in two different ways so in one way it's
interactive so the idea here is that you
can just put in a number a number a
number a number and you'll get back the
gis so that's what i'm showing here on
the top so you put in you you run the
script it prompts you for the GI number
you give it the GI number and then it
gives you a line with some numbers in it
and there's actually a bit of a
formatting problem here they're the
first number is the GI the second of the
point one is the accession version and
the 416 which got bumped up here my
apologies for that is the sequence
length alright so the length of the
sequence now another way that you could
do it which is honestly probably more
useful way after you're convinced that
it runs this is kind of a useful check
just to see does the script run is it is
it functioning is to give it a file of a
bunch all right of accessions and so
what you can do there's a number of ways
you can do this take a file put one GI
per line and then pipe that thing into
the script right and it will take that
and then output one line that looks like
this so give you the GI the accession
dot version and then the sequence length
back all right so now oh no a live demo
let's just say that all several times
and hopefully we'll have fun with this
and nothing terrible will happen let me
go ahead and just show you well let me
just show you what I've got here I've
been a unix linux environment I have a
few files here I've got my script so
here's the GI to accession pi script I
have the database there the rest of this
is basically some some Python files but
if I was simply to run the script like
this it gives me a
alright and so if I was to enter the
number 42 for example it gives me that
back and I can keep going right I know
another GI number see that's a good yeah
I number and right it will give me
something back if I enter something that
isn't a GI number it tells me it's not
found so this basically just allows you
to say okay does it work does it not
work and ctrl c ctrl d any of those
characters will take you out the more
interesting things is you have a large
number alright so let's imagine that I
have a file so what I've done is to
prepare a very simple file all right
there is it only has six GI numbers in
it so it's trivial case but that's the
kind of file that you need is input all
right so then I can just have the script
and I can just input that file directly
into the script and boom I get the
output all right so the output looks one
it's not a valid GI 10 right section
about version 406 it's the length 100 is
in The Ballad GI here's another one
here's number news another one notice
that it's agnostic about whether it's
nucleotide or protein it doesn't tell
you all right now those of you who've
been around in CBI for long enough and
use our resources enough may realize
that a CA a three-letter prefixed
accession is a protein and NP underscore
is a protein these guys down here are
nucleotides but it doesn't tell you that
the point is it's just a simple mapper
between a GI number and accession
version so how much can you do and how
long does it take all right well so not
to bore you all right with having to
wait around for things I went ahead and
created a file of GIS that include all
of the primate refseq GIS and nucleotide
so it turns out so I'm just going to
okay bunch of GIS alright if we look at
how many GIS there are there's about 2.8
million of those GIS so that's a
reasonable number in terms of that you
might want to convert all right how long
does it take the script to convert that
many in my hands it took me about 10
minutes all right so it's a really quick
process and you can have hundreds of
thousands millions of these things
you'll get a really quick it should
ideally conversion here's the idea right
so I get a whole big file with lots of
things in it now one of the things that
I would just point out since I did this
and was like this is interesting it's a
good thing to note there's a lot of not
found things here and what I did was I
downloaded the database on one day and I
did the test the next day and of course
most of these guys that you seen our
brand new and so they're not found so
when you see not found just be aware it
could be that it's an old GI all right
and it's not existed anymore or it could
be that it's brand new and it just came
in an innovation or the database is
updated with thousands and thousands of
GIS every day so you really want to run
it the same day to make sure you get the
most accurate information and i would
probably guess it for most people this
isn't a big issue because you're
probably dealing with GIS you already
have but in any case just be aware that
that's a dynamic that's going on all
right so let me go back to the
PowerPoint here after we survive that
and just finish up a bit so some other
things that are going to be happening
near future so in one of our previous
webinars I believe it was the sep tember
webinar we talked about a new ID type
parameter for the e-utilities that is
almost ready now and should be going out
in January and so that will allow the
e-utilities to accept accession versions
as their IDs and allow them to output
those you want more details about that
please refer back to the sep tember 7th
webinar where we discussed that in some
detail and we'll be having much more
publicity about that as as this goes
forward and just also keep in mind this
March date when GIS will no longer be
available in any of our flat file or
fast day presentations that includes all
of the things on the ftp site such as
the genbank and the refseq downloads
alright so I'm going to pause here thank
you everyone for your attention and if
there are questions please let us know
okay are we haven't us several questions
here one question is what about the
other databases that link to ncbi while
they continue to have GIS I not sure I
understand that question completely we
have no control about what happens to
the outside databases so if you want to
clarify that question please type it
into the question spot well second
question is which non database method is
appropriate for say 50 to 500 g I
numbers so if you have a small number 50
to 500 either way works you can
certainly use one effects URL to do that
number and that should be fine and that
means you don't have to download a
database and use this space for it so
I'd probably say you see fetch if you
have a small number like that the script
and database is really designed I would
say if you have more than like ten
thousand okay the last question has to
do with blast about the blast being
updated to handle GIS instead of the
sessions that's already the case so the
current version of blast which is 2.5
point 0 plus works with accessions just
keep in mind that the the GI numbers are
still present in the pre-formatted blast
databases so you can continue to use
those as you always have and then the
other question is I'm not clear why GI
number has changed to accession maybe
that question is about why we made this
change would you like to address that so
the if the basic question is like why
this is happening a couple of things we
can say is just in general over the
course of time we've had two different
ways of identifying sequences one being
the GI numbers and one being accession
dot versions in fact both of these
sequence identifiers are redundant with
one another in that they each uniquely
map to a particular sequence record and
most publications and journals require
accession numbers for publication of
sequences and that's more typical way in
the literature of referring to sequence
data another advantage of the accession
version over the GI is as I mentioned
earlier many of our sequence databases
in fact do not have GI numbers so
important resources such as the wgs data
sets and TSA status data set simply do
not have GI numbers at all and so the
only way that we can refer to those
sequences is by accession version so we
are moving towards a point where we can
universally access all of the sequence
data at NCBI any consistent manner and
that be an accession dot version another
follow-up question
think about blasts for making the GI
lists and things like that to limit
database access and blast so you can
pick which sequences you want to use
your blast database there is a CID list
option that can use accession numbers
we're working on making that option one
problem with that is that the index is
slower to run and so we're working on
making that faster I'm not sure whether
that will be out the next release or not
but you can currently do them with
accessions but they won't be as fast as
the GI numbers of present it's a couple
more questions it would be helpful to
know what the most popular letter
prefixes on the accession dot version
IDs refer to so some of that stuff is on
our ftp buzz on our website if you for
the refseq accession xin particular for
the insd the submitted accession numbers
that's a little bit more complex and
sometimes they're just purely arbitrary
the last question I see and probably the
last one that will take is if I submit a
new sequence it will have a new
accession or version update of an older
sequence so the answer to that question
is if you submit a new sequence it will
get a brand-new accession number and it
will be version 1 so we're continuing to
assign accession numbers because that
space is huge we can continue to do that
essentially forever okay I think that's
all we have time for today if you have
another question that's in the chat pod
that we didn't get to will answer that
in a document I'll turn it back over to
Eric now all right thank you Peter so
again thank you for your attention
hopefully this will be a useful utility
for you give it a try see what happens
let us know if you have any any
questions about that or problems with
that you can write to info INF 0 at ncbi
nlm nih gov I've put some other
additional points information up here
you can follow our blog which is NCBI
insights of the NCBI news and other
social media our Facebook and Twitter
channels for upcoming announcements
about GI and accession number issues
when these things are going to be
released when other changes may be
happening I will be continuing to do
additional webinars on this topic and
again if you are particularly interested
in the api's utilities hyphen announced
is an email listserv where we
announced that's changes and updates for
that community so you may want to sign
up for that and there's a link on this
slide lets you do that and again I'll
certainly you can write to info if you
have additional questions about that if
there's no other questions then I bid
you all happy holidays and thanks for
your attention and hope to see you soon
thank you
you